在之前的几个视频中，
Isa 展示了如何
构建一个使用 LLM 的应用程序，
从评估输入
到处理输入，
再到
在向用户展示输出之前
进行最终的输出检查。
向用户展示输出。
构建好这样的系统之后，
你如何知道它的运行情况？
甚至当你部署它并
让用户使用时，
你如何跟踪它的表现，
找出任何
不足之处，并持续
提高系统的
回答质量？
在这个视频中，我想和大家分享
评估 LLM 输出的一些
最佳实践，以及我想特别分享
构建这些系统时
的真实感受。
系统。
这个视频中我谈到的内容，
与你在更
传统的机器学习
监督学习应用中
可能见过的内容
之间的一个关键区别，
在于你可以如此迅速地
构建这样的应用程序，
所以评估方法往往
不会从一开始就
有测试集。相反，
你通常会
逐渐积累一组
测试样例。
让我解释一下
这是什么意思。
你可能还记得第二个
视频中的这张图，
关于基于提示的开发
如何加速
模型开发的核心部分，
从可能需要几个月
缩短到只需几分钟、几个小时，
或者最多
几天。
在传统的监督学习方法中，
如果你本来就需要收集 10,000 个
带标注的样本，那么
额外收集 1,000 个测试样本
的边际成本
并不算大。因此，在传统的
监督学习环境中，
收集训练集、
开发集
或留出交叉验证集
以及测试集，
然后在整个开发过程中
使用这些数据，
是很常见的做法。
但如果你能在几分钟内
就编写好一个提示，
并在几个小时内
让它运行起来，
那么如果你不得不暂停
很长时间
来收集 1,000 个测试样本，
会是很大的负担，
因为你可以在没有任何
训练样本的情况下
让系统运行。
因此，当使用 LLM 构建应用程序时，
通常的流程是这样的。
首先，你会在
少量样例上调试提示，
可能是一到三到
五个样例，并尝试
得到一个
能在这些样例上运行的提示。
然后当系统经过
更多测试时，
你偶尔会遇到
一些棘手的样例，
提示在这些样例上无效，
或者算法在
这些样例上失效。
在这种情况下，你可以把
这些额外的一两个
或三到五个
样例加入
测试集，以便
顺便添加一些
棘手的样例。
最终，
你积累了足够多的样例，
你慢慢增长的开发集
变得让人
不太方便手动
逐个运行每个样例
通过提示，每次
修改提示都要这样做。
这时你开始
开发度量指标，
来衡量这一小组样例的
性能，
例如平均准确率。
这个过程中一个有趣的方面是，
如果你在某一时刻决定
系统运行得足够好，
你可以就此停下，
不必
继续进行下一步。
事实上，有很多
已部署的应用程序
停在了第一步或
第二步，
实际上运行得很好。
现在，如果你手动构建的开发集
还不能给你
足够的信心来评估
系统性能，那这时
你可能需要进入
下一步，
即收集一组
随机采样的样例
来调整模型。
这将继续作为
开发集或留出
交叉验证集，因为
这样做
非常常见，可以继续
针对它调整提示。
只有当你需要更高精度的
性能估计时，
才需要收集和使用留出
测试集，即使你在调整
模型时也不去看它。
因此第四步往往
在这种情况下更为重要，
比如你的系统
91% 的时候能给出正确答案，
而你想调整它
使其达到
92% 或 93% 的正确率，
那么你确实需要更大的
样例集来衡量
91% 和 93% 之间
这些细微的性能差异。
只有当你真正需要一个
无偏的、公正的系统
性能估计时，
才需要
超越开发集，
另外收集一个留出测试集。
有一个重要的注意事项，
我见过很多
大型语言模型的应用，
其中并不存在实质性的
危害风险，即使
它给出的答案不太准确。
但显然，对于任何高风险
的应用程序，如果存在
偏见风险或
不当输出可能
对某人造成伤害，那么
收集测试集、
严格评估系统性能
的责任，
确保在使用之前
系统做出正确的事情，
就变得非常重要。
但如果，
例如，你只是
用它来
为自己阅读而
总结文章，
没有其他人，那么
危害风险相对较低，
你可以在这个过程中
较早停下，不必
花费代价去执行
第四和第五步，
收集更大的数据集来评估算法。
在这个示例中，
让我从
常用的辅助函数开始。
使用 utils 函数
获取
产品和类别列表。
在电脑和笔记本电脑类别中，
有一个电脑和笔记本电脑的列表，
在
智能手机和
配件类别中，
有一个智能手机和配件的列表，
其他类别以此类推。
现在，假设我们要解决的任务是，
给定一个用户输入，
比如"在预算有限的情况下
我可以购买哪款电视？"，
检索相关的类别和产品，
以便
我们有合适的信息
来回答用户的查询。
这是一个提示，如果你愿意，
可以随时暂停视频
仔细阅读。
这个提示
指定了一组说明，
并且实际上
给语言模型提供了
一个好输出的示例。
这有时被称为少样本（few-shot）提示，
或者从技术上说是单样本（one-shot）提示，
因为我们实际上使用了
一个用户消息和
一个系统消息来
给它提供
一个好输出的示例。
如果有人说，"我
想要最贵的电脑"，
我们就返回
所有的电脑，
因为我们没有定价
信息。现在，让我们在
这个顾客消息上使用这个提示：
"如果我预算有限，
可以买哪款电视？"
我们将提示、
顾客消息 0
以及产品和类别信息
一并传入。
这是我们使用
utils 函数
在顶部检索到的信息。
这里列出了与此查询相关的信息，
即电视和家庭影院系统
这个类别下，
看起来相关的电视和
家庭影院系统列表。
为了查看提示的效果，
你可以在第二个提示上对其进行评估。
顾客说，
"我需要一个智能手机充电器。"
看起来它正确地
检索到了数据。
类别：智能手机和配件，
并列出了相关产品。
这是另一个示例。
"你们有哪些电脑？"
希望能检索到
电脑列表。
这样我就有了三个提示，
如果你是第一次
开发这个提示，
有一两个或三个
这样的样例是很合理的，
然后继续
调整提示，直到
它能给出适当的输出，
直到提示能为
顾客请求检索到
相关的产品和类别，
对所有的提示
都能正常工作，
在这个示例中是所有三个提示。
如果提示遗漏了某些产品，
我们可能会
回去多次编辑提示，
直到它在这三个提示上
都能正确运行。
当你将系统调整到
这一步之后，
你可能会开始
进行测试运行。
也许把它发给
内部测试用户，或者
自己尝试使用，
只是运行一段时间
看看会发生什么。
有时你会遇到
一个失败的提示。这里
有一个提示的例子："告诉我关于
SmartX Pro 手机
和 FotoSnap 相机的信息。
另外，你们有哪些电视？"
当我在这个提示上运行时，
看起来它
输出了正确的数据，
但它也输出了这里的一堆文字，
这些额外的垃圾内容。
这使得
将其解析成 Python 字典列表变得更加困难。
我们不希望它输出
这些额外的垃圾内容。
当你遇到一个
系统失败的样例时，
常见的做法是
记录下来
这是一个有点棘手的样例，
所以我们把它加入
我们要系统性地
测试的样例集中。
如果你继续运行
系统一段时间，
它可能在这些样例上能工作。
我们确实在
三个样例上调整了提示，
所以它可能在很多样例上都能工作，
但只是偶然地，你可能会
遇到另一个产生错误的
样例。
这个自定义消息
也导致系统
在末尾输出
一堆我们不想要的
垃圾文本。
试图提供帮助而
给出所有这些额外文本，
实际上我们并不想要这些。
在这一点上，
你可能已经运行了
这个提示，可能在数百个样例上，
也许你有测试用户，
但你只需取出那些
系统表现不好的棘手样例，
现在我有了这组五个样例，
索引从 0 到 4，
这组五个样例
是你用来
进一步调整提示的。
在这两个示例中，
LLM 在末尾输出了
一堆我们不想要的
额外垃圾文本。
经过一点点尝试和调整，
你可能会决定
按如下方式修改提示。
这是一个新提示，
叫做提示 v2。
我们在这里
对提示做的修改是，
在提示中添加了
"不要输出任何不是 JSON 格式的附加文本"，
只是为了强调，
请不要输出这些 JSON 内容。
并使用用户
和助手消息
添加了第二个少样本提示示例，
其中用户询问
最便宜的电脑。
在这两个少样本示例中，
我们都向系统展示了
一个只给出
JSON 输出的
回复。这就是我们
刚刚添加到提示中的额外内容：
"不要输出任何不是 JSON 格式的附加文本"，
并且我们使用了
"few_shot_user_1"、"few_shot_assistant_1"
和 "few_shot_user_2"、"few_shot_assistant_2"
来给它提供两个少样本提示。
我按 Shift-Enter
来确定这个提示。
如果你回去手动重新运行这个
提示，
对所有五个用户输入
样例，
包括这个之前
给出错误输出的，
你会发现它现在
给出了正确的输出。
如果你回去重新运行
这个新提示，即
提示 v2 版本，对那个
导致错误输出（JSON 输出后有额外垃圾）
的顾客消息，
它会生成更好的输出。
我不打算在这里演示，
但我鼓励你
暂停视频，
自己重新运行
顾客消息 4
在这个提示 v2 上，
看它是否也生成
正确的输出。
希望如此，
我认为它应该可以。
当然，当你修改提示时，
做一些回归测试也很有用，
以确保
当你修复提示 3 和 4 上
的错误输出时，
没有破坏提示 0 上的输出。
现在，你可以想象
如果我不得不复制粘贴
5 个提示，
顾客消息 0、1、2、3、4，
放进
我的 Jupyter Notebook，
然后逐个运行并手动查看
它们是否输出了
正确的类别和
产品。虽然可以这样做，
我可以
看着它然后说："嗯，类别是电视和家庭
影院系统，产品，嗯，看起来
你
全都找到了。"
但实际上手动进行这个操作
是有点麻烦的，
手动检查或
查看这个输出，
用眼睛确认
这是完全正确的输出。
因此，当你调整用的开发集
变得不只是
几个小样例时，
开始自动化测试流程
就变得很有用了。
这里有一组 10 个样例，
我指定了 10 个顾客消息。
这里有一个顾客消息："如果我预算有限，
可以购买哪款电视？"
以及理想答案。
把这看作
测试集中的正确答案，
或者更确切地说，
我应该说是开发集，
因为我们实际上是在
针对它进行调整的。
我们在这里收集了
10 个样例，索引从
0 到 9，
最后一个是如果
用户说："我想要一台热浴缸时间机器。"
我们没有相关产品，
非常抱歉，所以理想答案
是空集。
现在，
如果你想自动评估
提示在这 10 个样例中
任何一个上的表现，
这里有一个函数可以做到。
这是一个相当长的函数，
如果你愿意，
可以暂停视频
并仔细阅读。
但让我先演示一下
它实际上在做什么。
让我打印出
顾客消息，
对于顾客消息 0。
顾客消息是："如果我预算有限，
可以购买哪款
电视？"
我们还打印出理想答案。
理想答案是这里所有的电视，
即我们希望提示检索到的。
现在让我调用提示。
这是
提示 V2，传入这个顾客消息
和
用户产品和类别信息。
让我
打印出来，然后调用
评估。
我们将调用
eval_response_with_ideal 函数
来查看回复与
理想
答案的匹配程度。
在这种情况下，它确实输出了
我们想要的类别，
并输出了
整个产品列表。
因此，这给它的评分是 1.0。
再给你看一个例子，
事实证明，我知道
它在样例 7 上出错了。
所以如果我把这里的
0 改为 7 并运行，
结果是这样的。哦，
让我也把这里更新为 7。
在这个顾客消息下，
理想答案是
它应该输出
游戏机和配件
类别下的内容。
即游戏机和配件列表。
但响应中有三个输出，
实际上应该有 1、2、3、
4、5 个输出。
所以它遗漏了一些产品。
如果我现在要调整提示，
我会使用循环
遍历所有 10 个开发集样例，
反复提取顾客消息，
获取理想答案，
即正确答案，
调用
LLM 获取响应，
评估它，然后
累加并取平均值。
让我运行这个。
这需要一段时间，
但运行完成后，
这就是结果。
我们运行了 10 个样例，
样例 7 错了。
所以
10 个中 90% 是正确的。
因此，
如果你要调整提示，
你可以重新运行这个，
看看正确率是上升还是下降。
你刚才在这个笔记本中看到的
是完成了
这个要点列表的第 1、2、3 步，
这已经提供了一个相当
好的由 10 个样例组成的开发集，
用来调整和验证
提示是否在正常工作。
如果你需要
更高水平的严格性，
那么你现在有了所需的软件，
可以
收集一组随机采样的
可能有 100 个
样例及其理想输出，
甚至更进一步
达到留出测试集的严格程度，
你在调整
提示时甚至都不去看它。
但对于
很多应用程序，停在第三步就够了，
但当然也有
一些应用程序，你可以做到
刚才在这个
Jupyter Notebook 中看到的内容，
相当快速地
获得一个性能不错的系统。
再次重申，
如果你在开发
安全关键型应用程序，
或者有
非微不足道的危害风险的应用程序，
那么当然，
负责任的做法是
实际上获取
一个更大的测试集
来真正验证
性能，然后
再在任何地方使用它。
就这样了。我发现
使用提示构建应用程序
的工作流程与使用监督学习
构建应用程序的工作流程
非常不同，
迭代的节奏感觉快得多。
如果你以前
没有这样做过，你可能会对
仅使用
少数手工整理的棘手样例
构建的评估方法感到惊讶。
你可能会想，
有 10 个样例，
对于几乎任何事情来说，
这在统计上都是无效的。
但当你实际使用这个过程时，
你可能会
感到惊讶，仅仅添加
少量几个棘手样例
到开发集，
在帮助你和你的团队
达到有效的提示集
和有效的系统方面
是多么有效。
在这个视频中，
输出可以被量化地评估，
即存在一个期望的
输出，你可以
判断是否给出了
这个期望的输出。
因此，在下一个视频中，
让我们看看如何在
"正确答案是什么"
稍微模糊的情况下
评估输出。
即正确答案
有点模糊的情况。